[MUSIC PLAYING]
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY:
Managing this complexity
feels quite overwhelming,
whereas when coming to cloud,
you want your infrastructure
to work flawlessly.
Ride the cloud.
Managed Instance Groups
on Compute Engine
help you handle all of the
problems above automatically
and build highly available
and scalable applications,
and also roll out the updates
automatically and safely
for you, so that you can
have a peace of mind, knowing
that your application
is well taken care of.
Today, we're going
to talk about how
to build your applications on
top of Managed Instance Groups,
how to deploy them, how to build
scalable and highly available
stateless load-balanced
application,
and also how to scale a
batch pool of workers.
And if you're already familiar
with the Managed Instance
Group, we have some
pro tips for you.
So let's start.
First, from the
application deployment.
You have your
continuous integration,
continuous deployment
pipeline that produces
a software build at the end.
And you could package this
software in three ways--
into a container image.
You could make a boot image
with all of your application
and libraries preinstalled.
This could maybe give you
a faster startup time.
Or you could use a
simple startup script
that would install your
dependencies in software
on the VM boot.
Any of these methods work
with Managed Instance Groups.
However, for this presentation,
let's look at an example
of how would you
deploy application
in a container image.
It is very easy and
only takes two steps.
First, you create
a virtual machine.
And then you check
the checkbox that you
want to deploy container
to this machine.
Specify your container image
and Docker runtime parameters.
For example, a
restart policy, or you
could pass some environment
variables to your container.
And that's it.
What will happen next is that
Compute Engine will create
a virtual machine for you.
This machine is
going to be based
on a container-optimized
operating system that
has Docker preinstalled and also
a container startup agent that
will start your
container on VM boot,
so you don't need to write any
scripts or start the container
yourself.
And in addition to all of
that, the container-optimized
operating system image is
supported and maintained
by Google, so you can
always use and get
the image with the latest
update and security patches
to create your new machines.
And if one VM is not enough, you
can create a group of machines
with the container.
First, you would create
an instance template
from a container image.
And then you would create
a Managed Instance Group
from this template, that
would then scale and create
as many VMs as you need.
And if your application
is load balancing,
you can attach it
to a load balancer.
Let's look at how it
works in practice.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: So
first of all, we
need to pull a container into
Google Container Registry,
so we can then use it.
So you can do it with a
simple Docker push command.
So let's go to the
Container Registry.
I've put a container
before the presentation.
So let's copy the
path to the container.
And now let's create a template.
Compute Engine.
Templates.
Let's call it the container.
GCE.
Let's provide a URL
for the container.
And let's allow HTTP traffic,
because our container has
a simple web server that
is serving applications,
so we can verify that it
works after it's been put up.
So now we have a template ready.
So now let's move to
the instance groups
and create an instance group.
So let's choose a zone.
Now we have to choose a template
that we've created previously.
We can turn off
autoscaling for now.
It will not be used.
We can set any number of
instances that we want.
And create.
So now we can see that
a Managed Instance
Group has been created.
So it usually takes
a little bit of time.
So refresh.
It should be ready by now.
Yeah.
And we can already see that
a Managed Instance Group is
created, and it's scaling up.
Let's go here.
We can see that all the
free VMs are up and running.
But remember that we have a
container, so the container
needs to be downloaded, set up.
There is also a firewall.
So if you want to look
at the details of what's
happening inside
of a VM, you can
go to the serial port console.
And we can see that the IP
table rules are being set up.
Now it's pulling the
container from the registry.
You can see that the
container is being downloaded.
Then it's being set up.
So it's up and running.
So let's verify if
everything works.
And it's ready.
Back to you, Mykola.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: So
in this simple demo,
we have deployed a
stateless application
on multiple virtual machines.
Now let's look.
How do we make this application
highly available and scalable?
First, a good example of
a stateless application
would be a web front end,
such as an online store.
You want it to be
highly available,
so that your users
don't get HTTP 500 when
checking out while shopping.
And you want it
to be scalable, so
that you can get all
the business that
comes your way on Black Friday.
And it's worth
noting that stateless
means that you manage your
machines like a herd of sheep.
You care about the
size, but you can easily
replace one machine
with another,
as they all do the same thing.
And they don't preserve
any state past VM lifetime.
So let's go back to the
problems that we have
discussed in the beginning.
What to do when your application
may stop responding or crash?
Managed Instance Groups
offer autohealing for that.
It promptly detects machines
with failed application,
and recreates them
for you automatically,
so that your users
are served again.
And you don't need to get
a page in such a situation.
It's all handled.
Autohealing is
configured very easy.
All you need to do is to
configure a health check
for your Managed Instance Group.
The way the health
check works is
that it pings each machine on
a specified path and protocol
and port.
Let's say myapp http 80.
It pings it on
regular intervals.
Let's say every five seconds.
And it expects an HTTP 200
response within the latency
that you pre-define.
And if the response
is not HTTP 200,
or if it takes longer
than three seconds,
then the health check
is considered failed.
And if this health check
fails multiple times,
the VM is considered
as unhealthy,
and will be taken
care of or recreated
by autohealing from
the instance template
where you have your well-tested
and stable configuration, so
that it can serve users again.
It's also worth noting
that health check not just
works with HTTP protocol, but
also with HTTPS, TCP, and SSL.
So it can be configured
in a very flexible way.
Now, Load Balancer also
uses health checking service
that is configured in
exactly the same way.
The difference, though, is
that Load Balancer does not
send new traffic to the virtual
machines that are unhealthy,
and sends traffic to the
machines that are healthy,
while original or a
Managed Instance Group
would recreate a machine
that isn't healthy,
which is a very different.
For that reason,
we highly recommend
using different health checks
for Load Balancer and Managed
Instance Groups.
Imagine a situation when
you have a machine that
is serving at full capacity.
So it cannot receive
any new connections,
and would be unhealthy from
a Load Balancer perspective,
so that Load Balancer needs
to redirect traffic somewhere
else.
However, it is still healthy
from the Instance Group
perspective, because
it is still serving
while these current
sessions of the application
is up and running.
And if you configure a more
aggressive health check
for Load Balancer--
let's say you do shorter check
intervals or shorter response
time outs--
you will allow Load
Balancer to redirect traffic
to less busy VMs.
At the same time,
autohealing will wait a bit
and will let the VM finish
the current sessions
and become available
again before it
makes the final decision
to recreate the VM.
Another tip for you is make
sure to set an initial delay
for autohealing to longer than
it takes for your application
to start serving.
During the initial period that
starts when VM is created,
autohealing will not
recreate a machine,
even if it is unhealthy.
This is to let your
application time to boot.
And of course, while it's
starting and initializing,
it's not serving.
So it's not going to
pass any health checks.
And you don't want it to be
recreated by autohealing.
So if you set the initial
delay to a higher value
than it takes for your
application to boot,
autohealing will
only recreate your VM
if it is unhealthy because
the application has failed,
and not because it just
hasn't started yet.
Let's look at how
autohealing works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: So we
have our instance group.
Let's look at how it looks like.
So we have two VMs.
Before I'll show you how the
autohealing works in practice,
I need to clarify some
things about this web server
application.
So this is written, as
I said, for the purpose
of this presentation.
And it has two
functions built-in.
The first one is reporting
the health status.
So that will be used to verify
that the VM is healthy and is
serving.
So we can verify
by clicking here
that it returns a response
200 and is serving.
So what I've done is I've
put a simple command that
will disable the health check.
So it will make the VM stop
reporting the health status.
As you can see,
this is not working.
So what now autohealing does
is it pulls the health status
from all the VMs
inside the group
to verify that the VMs are
healthy, up and running,
and everything is working.
And if it detects that
the VM is reporting 500,
or the applications
stop responding,
it will recreate it.
We can also look how
autohealing is set up.
So we go into the Cloud Console.
Health Checks.
We have an autohealing.
So as you can see,
we are looking
at the path health, so,
the same as I showed you
before in the application.
It's using protocol
HTTP, but you
can use TCP, HTTPS, SSL
on any port you want.
You need to specify
interval time out
and the number of consecutive
failures, et cetera.
So let's go back to
the instance group.
And as you can see, VM has been
detected that it's failing.
So it's being
recreated automatically
by the Managed Instance Group.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So now we have a group
of virtual machines
that are running.
And if an application fails, it
will be automatically detected,
and the VM will be
recreated by autohealing.
Great.
But what if a bigger problem
happens and the application
fails in an entire zone?
In this case,
autohealing won't help
because the root
cause of the problem
is likely not on a
single VM, but is
related to zonal configuration.
So to protect your application
against such a situation,
you would use a regional
Managed Instance Group,
and distribute your machines
across multiple zones,
so that should a
single zone fail,
your application can still serve
from the other available zone,
and the load balancer
will redirect traffic
to the healthy virtual
machines in those zones.
You can note here
on this picture,
that, however, you
will get only 2/3
of your capacity remaining
in the case of zone failure.
And if you care about
your high availability
so much that you want to
have enough machines to serve
your expected load, even
in case of zonal failure,
you should make sure that this
2/3 covers that requirements.
And in this case, you would
need to provision extra VMs.
Let's take a look
at the example.
Imagine, at this picture,
you need nine VMs
to serve your traffic.
So in order to protect
you against zonal failure
and still have
sufficient VMs, you
need to create extra VMs
so that should a zone fail,
you have, in this
case, 10 VMs available,
which is more than
nine, and enough
to cover your expected load.
In calculating how many VMs
you need to over-provision
to protect your workload
against zone failure is easy.
All you need to do is
to divide the number
of the VMs you need by the
number of the remaining
available zones.
So, for example, if
you deploy your group
to three different
zones, you need
to add 50% more VMs
that you regularly
expect from your workload.
This way, you would protect it.
Let's see how a regional
Managed Instance Group works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: OK.
So let's go to our regional
Managed Instance Group.
So as you can see,
we have three zones--
B, C and F. And in each zone,
we have two instances up
and running.
So there is also a load
balancer configured.
So you have to go to Networking
Services, Load Balancing.
Load balancer.
And here is the IP
of the load balancer.
So we can query
the load balancer
and see that on each refresh,
a different VM is serving.
So this application gives
you, as you can see,
the hostname that the zone that
the VM is in, and the template
is used that will be
used for the purpose
of the later presentation.
So what I've done is, I've
written a simple script that
will query the load balancer.
It will query all the VMs
and get the current zone
that the VM is in, and will
report it on the screen.
So let's run it.
So as you can see, all the
VMs are up and running,
or are serving from all zones.
So now what we can do is
simulate a zone failure.
So of course, I will
not bring down the zone
during the presentation.
But I can simulate it
by making the VMs report
unhealthy status.
So let's do it.
Regional.
Disable.
US-Central1.
And let's disable
zone F. Disable
the VMs in zone F.
There is central.
So now the health check
is configured the same as
in the previous demo.
So we need a few seconds
for Load Balancer
to see that the VMs
stopped responding.
As you can see, it
happens quite fast.
So now, our traffic is
served only from zone B
and zone C. So let's
bring down another zone.
Let's wait for a
few more seconds.
And as you can see, only
VMs from zone C are serving.
So now let's bring
all the zones back.
So what happens is,
the load balancer
queries the health
status of the VMs.
And if the VMs start reporting
that they are healthy again,
it will redirect traffic
back to those VMs.
So as you can see, we've
got, already, two zones up
and running.
And the third one
will be brought back
in a matter of seconds.
Back to you, Mykola.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So now we have a
group of VMs where,
if a single
application fails, it
gets automatically recreated.
And it is protected
against zonal failure,
because the VMs in the
other zones can still serve.
Back to the problems.
But what if a load spikes and
lands on insufficient capacity?
You don't want to lose
business because of that.
Or, what if a load goes
down, and you have idle VMs?
You don't want to
pay extra for those.
Autoscaler of the
Managed Instance Groups
makes sure that the group
has enough instances
to serve the load that you
have and adjusts the group
size in real time.
Configuring autoscaling
is also fairly simple.
You turn autoscaling on in
the Managed Instance Group
configuration.
Choose the scaling metric
that you want to use.
CPU usage is a very popular one.
Select the target
load for that metric--
for example, 60% CPU utilization
on average per single machine,
and specify constraints,
so that autoscaler does not
scale beyond these boundaries,
the minimum and maximum.
Let's say you want your
group size to be at least one
VM, but not exceed 10 instances.
And one more important
parameter is cooldown period.
This is how long an
autoscaler should
wait before taking a machine
into account since it
started booting.
This is important because
while the VM is booting,
it might have boot processes
that highly utilize CPU,
and which is not representative
of the regular serving load,
and could create a noise
for the autoscaling signal.
So if you set cooldown
period to longer
than it takes for your
VM to boot and stabilize,
you will make sure
that Autoscaler
will ignore these booting
instances while they're
loading.
And without this noise from
the signal, and as a result,
get more accurate group
sizings by the Autoscaler.
Let's see how autoscaling works.
Imagine you have a group
where the load spikes.
And in the current
number of the VMs,
the CPU usage goes
significantly above your target,
which is 60% in this example.
Autoscaler will
detect the situation
and add more VMs to bring
the average load back
to the target value.
And when, over time, the load
goes down, and becomes lower
than your target, autoscaler
will also detect the situation
and will remove the extra VMs,
again, to bring the load back
to the target.
A pro tip for you
is, if you want
to accelerate your scaling, you
should set up a lower target
value for it to maintain.
We can look at this
as an example--
an image, and you have
three VMs, all of which
are overloaded.
One is at 80% CPU
utilization, 70%, and 90%.
And if your target is
60%, the autoscaler
will resize it to four VMs.
And if your target is
40%, the autoscaler
will resize it to six
VMs, which is a faster
scaling that you could achieve.
Also, if you use autoscaling
together with regional Managed
Instance Groups, make sure
that you set a higher maximum
load than you expect for
your maximum demand--
a higher maximum number
of instances than you
expect for a maximum load, so
that Autoscaler has enough room
to scale up should
a single zone fail.
This is exactly the same
formula that you would
use for a non-autoscaled group.
The only difference is that
for the non-autoscaled group,
this formula would be applied
to the target number of VMs.
And these extra VMs
will be actually
running, whereas in the
autoscaled scenario,
you would apply this formula
to the maximum boundary
for the group size.
And the group will
reach maximum only
when it is needed
in those zones.
So let's see how
autoscaling works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: Instance Groups.
So we have an instance
group with only one
VM that is serving
the web application
that you've seen before.
So as I said, this web
application has two functions.
One is making VMs
report unhealthy status.
And the second one is generating
the high load on the CPU.
So what it does
in the background
is multiplying to run
the numbers in a loop.
So we'll have high
CPU utilization.
So let's start the function.
So in the mean time that we will
wait for the autoscaler to kick
in, let's look how it's set up.
So let's open the scaler.
So we have Autoscaling set
up based on the CPU usage.
I've set up the target
CPU size to 30%.
So the autoscaler would spin
up VMs a little bit quicker
for the purpose of
this presentation.
I set up the maximum number to
five and the cooldown period
to 15 seconds, because the
web server is a simple Python
script, so it takes a
few seconds to start up.
So let's go back.
So as you can see,
Autoscaler has already
detected the high load
on one of the machines,
and brought up the additional
VMs to compensate for the load.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY:
So now we have
a highly available and
autoscaled group of VMs.
But how do you handle updates?
How do you rollout
updates in a safe way,
making sure that your
users don't experience
downgrade of your service?
Auto-Updater allows you to roll
out an update in a safe way,
and in multiple
different scenarios,
and do it automatically.
When you do an update, you
want to, at the end of the day,
get your group from an old
version to a new version.
And the actual update is all
about the journey from that.
And you can configure this
and automate this journey
with the following configuration
options for the Auto-Updater.
The first one is, you
set up how far would you
like to roll out the update?
How many machines would
you like to update?
You could decide that
you want to update
half of the machines, or
maybe the entire group.
The second option
is, how many machines
do you update at a single time?
To roll out the
update carefully,
you don't necessarily
want to update all of them
at the same time.
You want to update one or
two, check that they work,
and then proceed.
A third option is, how
many extra machines
do you want to create in the
new versions temporarily?
This is useful
when you don't want
to take any of the serving
machines in the old version
down for an update,
and would rather
keep them serving as they are.
Create the machines in the
new version on the side,
wait until they are
healthy, and start serving,
and only then remove
the old machines.
You can also configure
how long an updater should
wait for the machine in
the new version to boot
and stabilize, to make sure
that it is truly healthy,
and only then proceed to
update in the next batch.
You can also configure
update action.
By default, it is a recreation
of a VM from a new instance
template.
However, you could also
use a rollout strategy
with the same instance template,
but restarting the VMs instead.
This is useful when update is
actuated within guest operating
system agents, such as pop up
agent, for example, on VM boot.
And finally, you can choose
update mode Proactive, which
will roll out the
update automatically,
or Opportunistic, in
which case, the updater
will only create machines
in the new version
when new machines
are really needed.
For example, when the
group is scaled up.
And it will only remove the
machines in the old versions
when you need to delete the
machines-- for example, when
the group should be sized down.
So important for
you is that if you
want to update some specific
machines at a specific time
and do it manually, you could
set up a new instance template
for your group, set update
mode to opportunistic,
and then recreate
those specific VMs
at the time when you want it.
Updater would
treat your creation
as an opportunity for
update, and these VM
will be created from the
new instance template.
Let's look at what
kind of scenarios
you could build with
this configuration.
Rolling update is
a very popular one.
This is when you
need to roll out
a patch to your whole group,
or maybe a new feature to all
of your users.
So you want the updater
allowed to the entire group.
New template 100%.
However, you want to
roll it out safely.
Let's say you want to update
three machines at a time.
Wait until they
are up, and if they
don't pass the health
check, stop the update.
You can do debugging, or
maybe decide to roll it back.
And if they do pass
the health check,
proceed to the next three,
and then the next three,
and so on, until the
whole group is updated.
Another useful scenario
is Canary update.
This is useful when you
want to do AB testing.
Let's say you have
an online web store,
and you need to roll
out a feature that
is expected to increase
your conversion to sales.
So you would set the new
template to, let's say, 30%
and wait for a week or a
month until you collect
enough statistics
to make a decision,
whether the conversion
has indeed improved,
and whether you should proceed
with the further rollout,
or roll it back.
The beauty of the Canary update
is that the Managed Instance
Group will keep this ratio
for you as the group scales.
You don't need to do
anything extra on your own.
So let's look at
how updater works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: So we
have a Managed Instance
Group that has six VMs.
All the VMs were created
from the first version
of our application.
So we can see that all of them
have instance template number
one as a source.
So to make this demo a
little bit more interesting,
let's use another
application that we've
written for the purpose
of this presentation.
So it queries the
VMs via the API,
and gets the current
status of a VM.
It can be creating, restarting,
deleting, recreating.
And it'll also show
you the version
of the instance template
that is used to create it.
So as you can see, all
the VMs are in version 1.
So now let's do
a rolling update.
Let's do a Canary update
in rolling fashion.
So that's just that
we want to have
our second version of our
application to be rolled out
to 30% of our VMs.
But we want to do
it in a gradual way.
So we want to only bring
down one VM at a time,
and provision an additional
VM at the same time, so we
would not pay too much
for the additional VMs.
But at the same time,
we'll keep the pool
of the VMs in a stable way.
So let's do the update.
And as you can see, the first
VM started to be deleted.
At the same time, the second
VM that we wanted to provision
has already been created.
So creating VMs is a little
bit faster than deletion.
So let's wait for a few seconds.
It usually takes
about half a minute.
So as you can see, the first
VM is already up and running
with version 2 of the template.
And as soon as the
second VM was created,
another VM is
being brought down.
And we are just waiting for
the first VM to be deleted.
Once the first VM is deleted,
we'll spin up an additional VM,
and the process continues.
We can also verify here that
the first VM is all ready.
Let's refresh.
The UI console is a little bit
slower than our application.
So as you can see, this
VM is being deleted.
We already have two VMs
with instance template 2.
So here is one.
Here is the second one.
And we can also
verify that we have
two VMs in the new version.
And the rest of the rest
two are being deleted.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: Another
useful update scenario
is fast rollout without
reduction in service.
This is useful when
you need to roll out
an update to your entire group.
However, you cannot afford
taking down any of the existing
instances, and would rather
create them on the side.
So you set the new
template to 100%,
because you want to roll out
the update to the whole group.
You set max
unavailable to zero, so
that it doesn't update any
of the serving old instances.
And you set max surge to 100%.
In this case, the
Managed Instance Group
will create the instances in
the new version on the side,
wait until they pass the
health check and start serving,
and only then will
remove the old instances.
As you can see, with
all of these settings,
you can build a quite flexible
and automated update scenario
that works for you.
It will roll out the
update if the new version
passes the health check
and is serving well.
And it will stop the update and
let you intervene if something
is wrong and the new
instances are not
passing the health checks.
Now, it's all good.
But how does Updater
work with autohealing?
Could, for example, when
you roll out an update
and all the instances
fail, could it
exceed your maximum
available budget?
The answer is no.
Let's look at an example.
Assume you set the max
unavailable to two,
and updates started rolling out.
It updated two VMs successfully.
All good.
But then an old VM fails
and is being autohealed.
Updater knows about it, and
reduces its max unavailable
budget to one.
So it will only take one
more instance for update.
And at the end, you will
get one instance updated
to the new version,
and the old instance
autohealed and serving.
So Updater and autohealing
work well together.
How about Updater
and autoscaling?
Could update rollout
interfere with the autoscaling
calculations?
Let's look at an example.
Let's say Updater took down
two machines for an update.
With the constant
load, this would
lead to a temporary
increase in the average load
for the remaining
serving machines.
However, autohealer is aware
about these two VMs that
are being recreated, and
will take them into account
when calculating the desired
number of the machines
for the whole group.
So it won't provision
any extra machines
beyond what you need, and
will wait for these machines
to boot up.
So Updater and autoscaling
coordinate their work
and work well together.
When rolling out an update to
a regional Managed Instance
Group, Updater will roll
out the new version evenly
across different zones
to distribute the risk,
and likewise, when removing
the old virtual machines,
it will also remove them
evenly across the zones.
Finally, when your
Managed Instance Group
is load balanced, and Updater
picks a specific machine
to update, it will follow
the following process.
First, this virtual machine
will stop receiving new traffic.
Then it will wait for the
connection draining timeout
that is configured
in the load balancer
to let the current session that
this instance serves finish
in a graceful way.
Then it will recreate the
instance from the new template,
wait until this instance
passes health check,
and only after that the new
machine will start serving
and will start
receiving new traffic.
And Updater will
proceed to the next one.
So there we have it.
We have built a scalable
and highly available
application on top of regional
Managed Instance Group
that can be load balanced.
And the group handles
all of the problems
that we've described above
automatically for you.
It handles VMs with failed
applications with autohealing.
It mitigates the
impact of zonal failure
by distributing your instances
across multiple zones.
It makes sure that
the size of your group
is tailored to the variable
load that it might experience.
And it also allows you
to roll out updates
successfully, and stop if you
get the unhealthy new version.
The main thing is that you can
pick any of these automated
services as you need, one
of them or multiple of them
or all of them together,
and do the rest if you
need your custom logic here.
And in the end,
have peace of mind
that your application
is well taken care of.
Now, let's look at how would you
scale a batch pool of workers.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: So what are
the main characteristics
of batch workloads?
So workers are not
needed at all times,
because you need it only
for the time of computation.
So you can bring
the workers down
if you don't have
anything to calculate.
So you optimize mainly for cost
instead of high availability,
like in the previous
presentation.
You also scale
based on the number
of jobs that are in the queue
instead of, for example, CPU,
because if you have
computations to do,
they are usually very
high CPU intensive.
So scaling based on
the CPU utilization
would not be as good as scaling
based on the number of jobs.
So to illustrate how to build
a scalable pool of workers
for batch processing,
let's look at an example.
So let's think about
an image stock service.
So usually how it works is
users upload their photos
to our service.
But before putting the
images into the internet,
we apply the watermark.
So it's a perfect example
of batch workload.
So how the architecture
might look like.
So the user uploads a photo
from a client application.
For the purpose of the demo that
I will show you in a minute,
we save it into
the cloud storage.
When the image is saved, we
also put the name of the image
into the PubSub task queue.
And then we create a
Managed Instance Group that
looks for this PubSub queue.
It watches for the number
of tasks that are in there.
And based on the
number of the task,
it will scale the application,
spin up additional VMs.
And we have a process
that is running
on these VMs that takes
the images from the queue,
the image names.
Then it downloads the images,
applies the watermark,
and then uploads them back to
the cloud storage, then output.
So how it looks like.
So you have a small number of
users that are putting images
into the task queue.
So we have a small
number of VMs.
But if the traffic grows,
so does the number of VMs.
But after you process all the
images that are in the PubSub
queue, autoscaling will
delete all of the VMs,
so you'll not have to
pay for them highly.
But if there will be
another pull of tasks
put into the queue, autoscaling
will pick them up and spin up
additional VMs.
So now let's take
a look at the demo.
So as you can see from the
previous updating demo,
all the VMs have been updated.
So first of all, I will show
you the images and the rest
a little bit later.
But first of all, let's put
some images into the queue.
So what this script does
is it pulls all the names
of the images from the bucket.
Then it puts them
into the queue,
so autoscaler could pick it up.
So let's take a
look at the images.
So as I said, they are saved
into the cloud storage.
So let's go there.
Open our project.
And we have two folders.
One is an input that has
images that I've uploaded
before the presentation.
They were taken from the recent
trip to the Italian Alps.
As you can see, the views
were quite spectacular.
And we have also an output
folder that is empty.
So let's go back to our
Managed Instance Group.
And let's see how
it is being set up.
So we've turned on
autoscaling, as before.
But this time, instead of
using scaling based on the CPU,
we've set up scaling based on
the stack driver monitoring
metric.
So what we are looking at,
and what is important here,
is that we are looking at the
number of undelivered messages
into the queue.
The rest is basically not
an interest in this now.
And we have to provide
the subscription name
so the autoscaler would know
which queue to watch on.
And also, what is important
that you can specify
the number of tasks per VM.
But what does it mean?
It is that autoscaler will
take the number of tasks
into the queue, divide
it by the number of tasks
that each VM can process,
and then spin up the VMs
to auto process this task.
So if you have 10 tasks, and
you have two tasks per VM,
you will have five
VMs in the end.
So let's go back
to the autoscaling.
Let's refresh.
And as you can see, we have
five VMs processing our images.
So we can go back
to the storage.
And let's see if there
are any images processed.
Yep.
It's already working.
And as you can see, we apply the
watermark-- the GCP Next logo.
And everything is
up and running.
Can we get back to
the slides, please?
And we have also
another tip for you.
So you can reduce the
cost of your service using
the preemptible VMs,
which can be up to 80%
cheaper than the usual VMs.
But there is a caveat.
The VMs last up to 24 hours that
can be preempted at any time.
But also, autohealing
works with them.
So if the VMs will
be brought down,
the autohealing will
watch for the capacity
of preemptible VMs.
If the capacity becomes
available again,
it will bring up the VMs again.
And also one thing to
note-- that these VMs will
be brought down gracefully, so
we'll get a 30 second notice.
So you can run your script,
for example, in a VM,
and save your workload on
a disk or gracefully close
all the connections.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: So
let's bring it all together.
We have deployed an
application in a container
to a Managed Instance Group.
We have also built a highly
available and scalable
application with the help of
autohealing, multi-zone zone
deployment, autoscaling,
and also can update it
safely and automatically.
And we have built a scalable
batch pool of workers.
Now, to finish, I want
to leave you with this.
If you need to
deploy an application
to multiple virtual
machines and have
full control over
your applications,
you don't need to do
everything by hand.
You can build a highly available
and scalable application
by combining the automated
features of the Managed
Instance Groups
that work for you.
You're not left on your own.
[MUSIC PLAYING]